i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
[Music]
[Music]
an eerie stillness chokes our lungs what
are you doing you know you were creeping
us out you know that right oh oh god
stay calm tea please
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's just chips
it's like you've given up on humans i
have a family now
they're giving me faith again
[Music]
and i see the good in humanity in them
every
single day
yes
[Music]
this
steam
engine i am sure you have something
simpler simple let's see
uh
ladies and gentlemen the plow
[Music]
now
[Music]
it's truly an honor to be in the
presence of the great eternals
so how did you end up scoring this
emerald tablet my beautiful beautiful
makari
[Music]
did you miss me
i'm sorry what are we watching because
this is youtube new because i hate
it do you think's going to lead the
avengers
i could lead them thor used to follow me
around when he was a little kid now he's
a famous avenger and won't return my
calls
[Music]
you